こんにちわ、はじめしゃちょーです
お前たち！
子どもの頃、ジャングルジム！　そう、　僕の、小学校の時の
唯一の友達。　うそです。
ウソですよ？友達居ましたけども、
ジャングルジムでメチャクチャ遊んでたんですよ、小学校の頃ね？
こうゆうね、解るでしょ？
トゥ、トゥ、トゥ、トゥ、ってこうゆう、
トゥン、トゥン、トゥン、トゥン、してるやつが有ったわけなんですけども
その、トゥン、トゥン、トゥン　ジャングルジムをですね、今日は
割りばしで、俺の家に、再現しようと思います。
大人になるとなんか遊具に魅力を感じちゃうわけなんですよ？　ん！
なので今日は、今日はね、こちらに、
割りばし千膳準備したので、この割りばし千膳を使って、
ジャングルジミング  を作ってみようと思います
千膳もあると　もうコンビニで　お箸要りません　て普通に言います
千膳売ってたことでビックリだからね
見たことねーもん千膳とか
どれだけの木が伐採された事か
ちゃんと、あのジャングルジム作った後もちゃんと食べますからね　このお箸を使って
資源を大事にしようね、みんな
今日はもうつべこべ言わずにとっととジャングルジムを作りましょう
話はそれからだ
先ずは土台から作っていきましょう
こういう感じだよね？
正方形を取りあえずメチャクチャ作ります
割り図に行きます。
強度を大事にて行きたいと思います。
ﾁｮとまだ範囲を決めてなかったんですけども
ﾁｮと  まだ 範囲 を決めてなかったん ですけども
なるべく大きいのを作ってみようと思います
取りあえずこんなもんで、一回ちょっと立ててみましょう
もう 立たなかったら 失敗ですからね、 これ
あ、何とか行けそう  何とか立つ
一応ね、多分ね、行けそうです
行けそうなんですけども、、、多分これねぇ
相当時間かかるね
徹夜じゃん、今日もぉー
「これは世よにも有名な物見やぐらですね」
「えーっ、ｽｺﾞｰｲ先生、物見やぐらって一体何なの？」
「そうだねぇ、 敵が攻めて来た時ね？  物見やぐらから  上を見て  敵の攻撃を  防ぐんだよ？」
「えーっ、ｽｺﾞｰｲ先生、そうなのね？」
「そうだよぉ？次のテストに出るから、しぃっかり覚えるんだよぉ？」
「わかーった、先生～。　も　の　み　や　ぐら」
は～い
ものみやぐら～♪
ええ～～３時間掛かっております。
三時間 でやっと、 この レベルです
はい、と言う訳で  完成しました～
ﾁｮ、待って、、、、もう、、もう限界
はい！と言う訳で、
制作時間  約4時間位ですね
全然まだまだ行けたんですけども
下の方の強度がだいぶやられてて
だいぶ傾いて来てます
けっこう傾いちゃってるんですけども
うわ～やべ～
スゲ、夢のようだな
早速遊んでみましょう